do i just do i start
thank you very much for gathering today
ladies and gentlemen my name is henry
golding i
am with gq and these are my 10
essentials
[Music]
my number one essential for wherever i
go wherever i travel
a camera could be any sort of camera
this in particular
is a 35 mil sort of film camera leica m6
with a 28 summicron on it i usually
shoot 35 because that's the perspective
of the eye
but i also have a fujifilm i have a gf
670 medium format which i love shooting
as well but i find
you are never alone in any city if
you're with your camera just rambling
the streets looking for a good
opportunity to take a photo
these have traveled the world with me
these
have been my shape and sunglasses of
choice for pretty much the longest time
one because it's really tough to find
glasses that fit my gigantic head
two ones that compliment me i think
these are the larger size because the
small ones look like i'm just wearing
these like bottle caps so these work
really well
prepare to be wowed by
cheesecake yay
this will be my third cheesecake i have
had in the past 24 hours
logo my mom allowed us to have
any cake we wanted for our birthday but
me and my brother
we consistently every single year was
like just just cook us
or prepare us a cheesecake so for me it
always brings back
sort of memories of you know my
childhood and my mom
sort of making the digestion used to
crumble up digestive biscuits and
kind of put them as a base and then make
the sort of the cream on top
and they would be simple we wouldn't
have any of the garnishes or the compot
as you see here but it's very very hard
for me
to say no to cheesecakes i'm a huge
fan of perfumery fragrances
there's a few that i continuously buy
one of them
lalabo centaur 33 really classic
but my list i've literally got like
three three on my hit list
many from frederick mall who is a uh
parisian perfumer number one portrait of
a lady
number two musk ravager my fourth
must-have on the list is uh tom ford
black orchid as well as
neroli it always kind of reminds me of
the times of
of traveling in like positano and places
like that
with the scent of orange blossom in the
air so i always
kind of match my perfumes to the day
the evening whatever it is so santa is
much more of a day smell
frederick mile portrait of a lady much
more of an evening have yourself a good
collection these are fairly expensive
but
you don't use them all too much if they
are strong
my wife made this but it has liv and
lila with a little heart
for henry which she gave to me when i
was away for
a solid month so every time every
morning i would spray and i kind of look
at that message
santa for me um very kind of
a little bit spicy wooden i'm gonna get
it all wrong ood
and that kind of jazz i don't know all
the buzz words but
i know it smells great and a lot of
people love this better send me some
free
perfumes after this geez
[Laughter]
next item i would say 90
of my t-shirts that i own are black
this one in particular is dolce gabbana
but i
use uh buck mason shirts as well
i think they were founded in venice and
a local los angeles brand
they have a great sort of oyster cut on
the back and kind of gives you a little
bit of shape
they have got more expensive so you must
be doing well bug mason
so this one makes a lot of noise
leather jackets i am forever sort of
living in leather jackets this one
it's a beautiful i think it's a calf
leather
i know touchy subject but yeah i i have
a tremendous amount of sort of leather
jackets everything from
this one's again dolce gabbana bell
staff do some fantastic sort of
motorbike jackets as well as some
outdoor outdoor jackets that i love
barbados
has a fantastic fit as well but i'm
loving these dolce banner right now
because they they have a great
a great fit and great colors don't be
afraid to sort of step
out of the whole black leather thing go
for some color spice it up
my love for leather jackets i guess it
stems
from trying to look cool is that good
enough for a reason
okay
green juices the world would be a much
happier place and everybody had a green
juice to start their morning
this one has some cucumber some spicy
stuff some ginger maybe but it's meant
to sort of
give you that little burning sensation
in the back of your throat because you
know it's doing good stuff whenever i'm
i'm on a full day on set i have like an
endless supply
of green juices the trick behind making
green juices
sammy taste good i think is the
abundance of
ginger if you're putting like terrible
stuff like kale in it no good
spinach passable cucumber fantastic but
apart from that what else they put in
green juices like green beans and
i don't know
hot sauce is a must with
any meal not particularly cholula i do
love cholula definitely
more so whilst moving to sort of america
in malaysia i love sambal blachchan
which is
chiles with fermented shrimp fried up
and kind of mixed with delicious kind of
asian delicacies but hot sauce wise
nothing more than
something that's going to burn your
taste buds and destroy your meal i've
made that mistake
in the past one of my friends john
bernardi
his son brought out this hot sauce uh
which i think is called the
end i thought they were joking but they
were like oh we had to like sign this
waiver
it was like really hot i'm like yeah
okay whatever we decided to sort of have
a drop of of the end and i literally was
in tears for about an
hour just like choking my friend had to
go to hospital it wasn't a good night
for for the both of us
my ninth essential item
has to be my wedding ring i actually got
this
in the backwaters of kerala
and indian gold is one of the only golds
with
a tremendous amount of sort of hue and
color i never
leave home without it if i have to take
it off for a roll it goes into one of my
very safe pockets
and then at the end of it it goes right
back on
last on my list i pretty much never
travel without them a pair of
wallabar brown swim shorts these are
fancy ones
with a picture of guys sailing around
the world somewhere
fancy i love all about rounds just
because of the sheer fit
they have the sort of side clasp which
you find in
fine men's tailoring they're very sort
of unique in that sense
and they're very much the european cut
of
like a good five six inches above the
knee
a good pair of wallabar brown swim
shorts
never goes without me anywhere i love
the water i grew up on the beaches of
malaysia and so as a kid i would spend
countless hours kind of in the ocean in
and around
on on the sand sort of just daydreaming
so
has a very close sort of thing for me to
uh
connecting me to my past well that's it
guys that was my 10 essential items i
want to thank gq for having me
you guys for watching and don't forget
stay guys